[Musik]
hey ihr lieben heute gibt es eine
leckere torte mein papa zum beispiel der
lieblos und habe ihn letztens als er
frührentner geworden ist habe ich ihm
loriot torte gemacht das habt ihr im
blog gesehen und hab gesagt kiddy muss
uns doch mal zeigen und da habt ihr
vollkommen recht die ist gar nicht mal
so kompliziert aber dafür richtig
richtig köstlich ich habe jetzt hier
einmal schon vorbereitet meint
schokoladen biscuit boden
dafür gibt es ein extra video damit
dieses video auch nicht so lang gehalten
ist und ihr darauf immer zurückgreifen
könnt dann brauchen wir natürlich los
hier habe ich noch etwas cacau ganz
normal trinker kauf für die böden
mascarpone vanille extrakt und sahne
fest hier habe ich puderzucker und
schlagsahne und jetzt beginnen wir mit
der schlagsahne tipp nummer eins sie
schlag sein um es ganz frisch also ganz
kalt aus dem kühlschrank kommen genau
solche kraft dass wir drücken ganz genau
haben sie schon gelernt mit dem schnee
also der schneebesen aufsetzt und die
schüsse die bestenfalls auch für 10 20
minuten in den kühlschrank stellen es
ist ein fataler fehler wenn ihr das zum
beispiel gerade heiß waschen oder so und
dann hier drauf gelegt und dann wird die
sagen auf jeden fall gewinnen die wird
auf jeden fall nicht steif daher diese
tipps beherzigen
jetzt gehe ich die sache in die maschine
schlag diese unfair 30 sekunden an und
gibt dann acht teelöffel sahne fest dazu
und dann auf höchster stufe vollständig
steif schlagen
[Musik]
so die sahne ist schön steif geschlagen
wir verwenden sie jetzt sofort weiter
würdet ihr euch jetzt ein bisschen zeit
lassen dann gibt die sahne auf jeden
fall in den kühlschrank aber ich beeile
mich jetzt daher ist es kein problem
wenn sie eine minute hier steht jetzt
gebe ich mascarpone in eine große
schüssel zusammen mit dem puderzucker
und den mann in ein extrakt und da kommt
auch noch mal ein bisschen sahne fest
rein
ich rühre das ganze dann mit einem
schneebesen um und habe dann die sahne
mixx aber unter
[Musik]
so fluffig dies unsere creme die wird
gleich noch aufgepimpt und das tolle ist
ich benutze jetzt zum befüllen zum
bestreichen und für die sahnehäubchen
also wir haben hier 3 1 1 quasi wichtig
ist jetzt die creme in den kühlschrank
geben das mache ich jetzt sofort und
nutzer aber die zeit um dann die hausse
die kekse der ubs von der weißen creme
zu befreien die weiße klebt brauchen wir
in diesem rezept nicht aber nicht
wegschmeißen es könnt ihr euch ja auch
bewahren und in irgendwas anderes
weiterverarbeiten einfach so naschen und
dann geht es auch schon weiter
[Musik]
den großteil der urus habe ich jetzt
meinen blender ganz ganz fein gemahlen
und einen kleinen teil habe ich nur grob
geschnitten das brauche ich dann später
für die äußere deko und falls ihr euch
jetzt wundert kiki wie viel brauchen wir
denn von all dem ich schreibe euch immer
die ganz genauen mengenangaben unten in
die video beschreibung einfach neben dem
titel den fall anklicken und dann
gelangt ihr direkt dorthin und jetzt
habe ich hier meinen schoko bizkit boden
und der wird jetzt zweimal durch
geschnitten so dass wir drei bühnen
erhalten
[Musik]
schaut euch den boden an richtig
feinporig habe ich gestern abend
vorgebacken und der ist einmal der beste
also wie gesagt auch das rezept verlegen
die ich euch in die video beschreibung
satz habe ich mir die creme aus dem
kühlschrank geholt und gebe einen teil
also gerade so ein bisschen weniger als
die hälfte in eine schüssel also eine
separate schüsse und gebt da die
gekreuzten oreo kekse reinen das ist
unsere füllung für außen brauchen wir
dann wieder eine weiße krähe helle creme
ohne die oreo kekse daher mache ich das
alles mal gerne separat di orio füllung
ist fertig und ich habe die restliche
creme auch schon wieder in den
kühlschrank gepackt denn ihr kühlschrank
ist heute unser freund also damit die
rechtlich zu hause verzweifelt immer
wieder kühlen und ich nehme jetzt hier
wieder mein konstrukt
ich habe immer haben ein konstrukt wenn
nicht orten macher und zwar besteht das
aus meiner drehbaren tortenplatte die
hier aus glas dann habe ich hier die
tortenplatte auf der torte serviert und
meinem tortenring damit auch alles schön
gerade an den seiten nach oben geht und
es macht
na ja und ich mache das jetzt so dass
ich mir einen boden nehmer und ich
trinke den er jetzt mit dem trinker kauf
einfach so damit ich so ein bisschen
schokolade gehabt könnte auch darauf
verzichten also an sich sind die böden
jetzt nicht trocken sondern super super
saftig und lecker und da gebe ich jetzt
ein bisschen trick um drauf gibt dann
die orior füllung dazu in schichten wir
das bisschen mit dem letzten bogen
abschlüssen
[Musik]
die torte befüllt und ich gebe jetzt
damit die oberfläche auch nicht
austrocknet mein kate obendrauf kate
kate kickboard und so gebe ich jetzt
meine torte für eine halbe stunde in den
kühlschrank danach lösen wir den
tortenring und werden so rundherum
einstreichen etwas zeige ich euch gleich
auch noch mal ganz gerührt
[Musik]
so ihr lieben nach der kür zeit mit
einem tortenring messer am rand entlang
fahren damit da auch nichts mehr am
tortenring kleben bleibt wenn ihm
entfernt jetzt nehme ich ihn einmal weg
von der torte und bestreichen sie mit
der weißen krähen liebe diesen moment
sieht man immer so gut aus nachdem
einstreichen wie die torte für zwei
stunden in den kühlschrank gegeben und
dann kümmern wir uns um die deckung die
kühl zeit ist wichtig erheben damit das
ganze ein bisschen fester wird und wir
jetzt den schoko trip ganz einfach
darüber geben können ohne dass
irgendetwas verläuft und für den schub
habe ich hier schon was vorbereitet und
zwar habe ich tat bitter kuvertüre und
butter eine mikrowelle bei geringster
watt sei geschmolzen und die zwar ruhig
das und dann gebe ich einfach den tipp
auf die torte
[Musik]
jetzt lassen wir den schoko diät einmal
ganz kurz aus herten ich glaube dass
jetzt einfach in den kühlschrank für
circa 10 15 minuten und dann spritze ich
mit meiner rosen tolle richtig schöne
tupfer auf die torte mit der restlichen
creme sollte nämlich auf jeden fall für
die tupfer noch was übrig haben laut
einer berechnung und dann gebe ich nur
noch halbe oberes drauf und dekoriere
den rand mit meinen klein gehackte
norovirus so ich werde immer langsamer
das ist immer wenn ich nicht auf was
freuen sich einfach immer langsamer und
gemüse die sätze die ich sage richtig
verrückt also ihr seht gleich die deko
und dann schneiden wir zusammen an
[Musik]
und fertig ist die perfekte orio torte
ich finde nicht dass eine orientierte
immer hoch und mächtig sein muss sondern
einfach auch mal locker leicht wir haben
jetzt die sahne mascarpone creme und
innen auch mit den ohren keksen
aufgepeppt was ich wichtig finde der
boden ich habe jetzt extra ich meinen
saftigen schoko boden genommen der ist
zwar lecker aber ich habe extra darauf
verzichtet und dem lokal eichen schoko
bizkit genommen damit die torte nicht so
schwer ist in eure gäste nicht sagen
auch mensch liegt aber richtig schwer im
magen nein also so ist die definitiv
nicht und ja davon meist nichts gefragt
hast doch sahne und sony das ist gar
nicht so genau wie ist schön niedrig
diesmal gehalten und überhaupt nicht
deftig also macht sie unbedingt nach
wenn ihr fans von oreo torten seit ich
muss euch ganz ehrlich sagen
kurios an sich hätte ich nie erreicht
mich gar nicht so aber in torten
verarbeitet finde ich richtig leckeren
kings vor allem in krems ganz genau und
wenn er jetzt noch ein paar
geburtstagskerzen obendrauf packt dann
habt ihr die perfekte geburtstagstorte
bestimmten oder also ich finde es
einfach nur hübsch aus unbedingt
nachmachen schaut in die video
beschreibung wie gesagt für alle ganz
genauen mengenangaben und wenn die
bisher hingeschaut habe und euch die
torte anspricht dann hinterlasst doch
gerne jetzt ein bisschen nach oben
damit ihr uns auch etwas zurückgibt und
in die kommentare wird für die nächsten
wünsche dann kann ich darauf allen gehen
und canvas nächstes was heute siehst du
was zaubern so ganz auf der torte weil
wir gleich auch naschen werden
aber euch verabschiede ich jetzt erstmal
und sage bis zum nächsten mal auf die
couch in chips
[Musik]